entre muchas dudas sobre qué pasó con el
indigenista bruno araujo y el periodista
abdón phillips en la amazonía brasileña
los investigadores están un paso más
cerca de conocer la verdad después de
que dos de los principales sospechosos
por su desaparición confesaron haber
participado en su asesinato
el pescador amarillo duda costa alias
pelado reconoció haber quemado sus
cuerpos junto a su hermano pero aseguró
que fue una tercera persona que los
asesinó el periodista británico don
phillips y el experto indigenista bruno
araujo pereira trabajaban en una
investigación cuando el 5 de junio
partieron de la comunidad de san rafael
atalaya de un norte en el valle de
javarí un viaje de aproximadamente tres
horas que nunca terminó para ellos
pasaron por la comunidad de sao gabriel
donde vive amaré a toda costa y se les
vio por última vez en la comunidad de la
calle era cerca de donde encontraron a
sus pertenencias esta región de la
amazonía es vecina de perú y colombia- y
cuenta con el mayor número de
comunidades indígenas incomunicadas pero
también se caracteriza por su
peligrosidad debido al narcotráfico la
caza furtiva y la minería y la maderería
ilegal la situación de nuestros colegas
y esta es la situación de nuestros
colegas expertos indígenas en la zona es
desesperante están en sobrecarga en
shock agotados necesitan todo el apoyo
al igual que los indígenas es
precisamente todo apoyo
así como sentirse el presente mes
necesitamos urgentemente el despliegue
de fuerzas del orden para garantizar la
seguridad en esta región fronteriza
frontera las autoridades sospechan que
el móvil del asesinato está relacionado
con la pesca ilegal en la zona en
especial de un pez protegido el pirarucú
aunque aún faltan por confirmar los
detalles de la autoría del crimen